>>Alton Brown: Hi.
Alton Brown here.
I'm shooting this video live at the New York
City Food and Wine Festival, or Wine and Food
Festival.
Anyway, I'm gonna be doing a talk right here
on YouTube and we want to hear from you.
We wanna get your questions so I can answer
them during the chat.
Now, anything you've been dying to know about--Good
Eats, Next Iron Chef, Iron Chef America, or
just plain old cooking like a turkey dinner,
things like that--here's your chance to ask.
Submit your questions via video or just question
at YouTube video backslash at GoogleTalks
and while you're there, you can vote on the
questions that you would most like to hear
me answer.
Now, you're gonna have until noon Pacific
Time on Tuesday, October 11th to send in your
questions.
So, what are you waiting for?
Make sure to tune to our live stream on Wednesday
at 10 AM Pacific Standard Time.
That's it for now.
I'm Alton Brown.
I bid you good eating.